welcome to this video playing drama da I
am drama da its Jasper hall right yep
yeah he's playing the chick benoni or
some weird form of that I think no e5 or
something no he goes to that it's not
hmm that's an early a6 really ok
shouldn't spend so long him just play
out some bowls it's very honey I don't
know if I can do something with that
just plain normal stuff trying to not
fall far behind on time yeah I've played
him before not with a good score but I
remember that I was winning in all of
the games so seems to be a tricky
opponent for me
totally Peregrine I don't believe in
this kind of play at all so let's see
what what happens here like it's just
reckoning himself enormously for some
wake active play that might or not be
happening okay but should be 54 Queen
age for what exactly is the idea maybe a
g3 weekends the light squares quite a
lot I probably wait until he goes /
should be 5m ok I'm not sure complicated
it's definitely a complicated position
ok
okay let's prevent neither form yeah
question do you want to check their on
c3 and take it for maybe he wants to do
that it's not really possible okay let's
activate the rock I'm going to put it on
b6 here and might or might not be a good
spot for it threatening Bishop c5 just a
little coincidental threat but well it's
not so easy to meet actually he might be
able to take a c3 and e4 I mean I'm not
saying that it's totally impossible to
play it just looks very risky to do with
his weird night on age 5 and so on g5
played Bishop c5 is not so easy to head
to meet I don't you don't have a queen
move that does something against it
hmm
right sure I think I had something very
similar against him before some we had
been Oni yeah so he does not really do
anything against it rook c8 probably
have that my membership see are both
hanging yeah that's definitely that's
definitely on them okay we should be
five their way to I can't go nite a form
maybe this is a move it might have
Knight f6 en this position now okay that
was an interesting way to play there
should be five Bishop c5 rook c8 our
mean that this this looks we add up I
had tell have a move there what Bishop
another six is coming
Knight f6 Bishop f4 is my idea right
very very complicated stuff hard too
hard to evaluate if it takes Queen takes
that that looks really great iam so I
don't think he can do that so what is he
going to do if he takes Bishop if he
plays Bishop d 4 i'm going to take on d6
he might take on c3 but well there are
limits to what you can calculate it in a
blitz game I think yeah he has to do
that it's probably probably the only
only move and here Knight takes Queen
seen one which I really cannot evaluate
maybe that's good for black it's
possible I'm still having some kind of
pressure there and possibly Bishop d3
4-pin yeah it's hard to say
especially with coming time issues
anything can happen them yeah I was
still thinking about 53 here
so that i get d six at the end he might
have some technical tricks though
discoveries 93 or whatever I'm not sure
this
maybe I can tick check out on a six on
b7 I could have taken the six maybe now
I couldn't see for saying no maybe I
could have taken I don't don't really
know ok it's not attacking c3 really so
I can I think I can take here
and don't like my king position very
much Knight coming to f3 or any kind of
weird tactic
yes I did not really expect that move
time morning well I cannot this is
something which is beyond my calculation
ability III hangs right can't stick
there's some kind of trick I don't know
I don't see it and there wasn't a trick
right but I can do this this is this is
quite strong I think look on the six
wrinkle black resigns yep so breaking
2500 after after some some while very
close to my high score 27 points shy
from that who yeah those kind of this is
kind of wacky be no knees they're tricky
to play let's have a look there this
this is a complicated line I think this
is nothing special for why it's just an
old old line against the Benoni quite
solid but I really don't believe in
those g pawn moves maybe this is ok but
I always feel like the long-term
weaknesses should mean something now
that is quite active huh ok this is g3
is not clear if it's necessary compounds
to go rook b3 and gives me a great
position why actually Bishop a 6 is the
threat right and computer has completely
unfazed by this kind of thing yeah okay
he's not threatening anything yeah
that's not clear what he what he's doing
if he does that I go and going him to
ghanem I having this is a nice rook
there I did this later in the game but I
only wanted to I wanted to have I wanted
to have this this night f4 out of the
picture but it was always weakening the
lights
yes yeah the engine wants to pick here
still giving why the clear edge yeah
unless something terrible is happening
to me immediately I will always have in
a decent position here because of his
long-term weaknesses and he's got some
some structural problems still surprised
that the comp is giving one point form
means that this is really not not any
good yeah this is what you did yeah I'm
not sure about this plan Jim still seems
to be decent yeah I played many comp
moves yeah that's so pretty good rookie
3m I was thinking I should give this
bishop this look some kind of safe
square now I could have taken these six
now I did not I saw that just too late I
could have taken him using the pin I was
only seeing that there is pressure oh
that's a weird way Darrell that there is
this kind of thing yeah and it was
possible should be seven again this was
was really losing yes I was kind of
irritated but at least I found Bishop b5
to completely kill off everything here
well I was a shaky game so the next one
will be will be interesting with one
winner going to break I would break my
all-time high with the chess explain
account okay well thanks for watching